first of all let me start with
congratulations thanks um if someone has
never seen anything you've done before
what is the first thing you want them
watching and why that's a good question
uh what's super bad
check out Superbad people seem to like
it seems to hold up well one of the
first things I ever wrote about my
childhood specifically you'll get a good
sense of what I think is funny and who I
am as a person
I will also recommend that film it's
it's kind of good yeah
it's kind of good um so uh what is it
like because you've been in this
business for a little while what is it
actually like getting a phone call or a
text or an email however you got it
from Steven Spielberg basically saying I
want to meet you for something
um it was crazy I I got a call that uh
yeah there was a zoom was arranged I
heard he wanted to zoom with me it was
in the midst of the pandemic
um yeah I didn't know what it was about
honestly at all
um I thought maybe it was about writing
something maybe potentially rewriting
something brought into fixed comedies
that are not doing as well as they could
uh things like that uh but no he said
that he had written a movie with Tony
Kushner and there was a role in it that
they kept talking about me for as they
were working on it and and that he
wanted me to read the script and then we
should talk and I was like I'm gonna
want to do it I don't know if I need to
read the script he was like just read it
and I read it and lo and behold I wanted
to do it and
um and I was like yeah I'm in and then
he was like great I'll put the rest of
the movie together I'll let you know
what's happening then yeah I over the
next few months that I would talk to him
periodically is he kind of filled out
the rest of the cast and from the
shooting plan and then it was just this
lovely thing I knew was gonna happen
months in the future and I just uh yeah
it was I was just so excited honestly at
any point did you think he was filming
an episode of punked there was I I was a
little
yeah I wanted to I did doubt its
validity at times
um last night I spoke to a little bit
and you mentioned that you went to set
before filming began yeah lots and so
I'm curious when even though you're in
the movie you're one of the stars do you
actually have to ask someone permission
to go to set when you're not filming
of
permission I mean kind of yeah you kind
of gotta you don't know what all sets
are different and sometimes they don't
like people on set who aren't like
working specifically I was pretty sure
it would be okay and I told him
beforehand that I wanted to so it wasn't
like I couldn't imagine they would say
no you got to find out where they're
shooting and [ __ ] like that they tell
you in a park and stuff so like there's
some they need to know you're coming I
guess to some degree but uh but no they
were happy to uh they were yeah he
seemed everyone seemed happy to have me
I am I'm curious you've obviously
directed your own things and you've
acted in tons of projects how is
Spielberg set different in maybe ways
you did not expect because he is a
genius yeah and I'm just curious how he
runs a set versus maybe how you run a
set
there's a few things that were
interesting it's
you know I would say the closest thing I
had done from a writing perspective and
how it was expected to be performed to
some degree was this Aaron Sorkin uh
Danny Boyle film and that movie we
rehearsed for like six weeks for this
movie by Tony Custer as he was Spielberg
gets written on the screenplays looked
very similar very specifically laid out
went to overlap went to stop but there
was no rehearsal at all and Stephen did
not want to rehearse at all and so that
was really different and something that
was really exciting and I actually
really liked it and it was it was it was
cool and I think it was
it's funny the closest I've seen to it
is that like scoring sessions where like
all the compo all the musicians show up
and they've never played the song
together but they all know their part
and the composer just like one two three
go and everyone just boom and it it just
happens you know and there were times
where it felt like that where it was
like I know my part and if everyone else
knows their part and we just go then it
might really just come together in this
amazing way and and and it did all the
time
um and so that was interesting but
to some degree it's like watching you
know like I would assume like you know
so like Michael Jordan played basketball
to a basketball player and it's like you
can learn some things but the
overwhelming lesson you take away is
like he is not doing this in the same
way most people are and therefore
there's a limit to what you could learn
from it you know like the speed and
proficiency with which he could block
and decide how to shoot the scenes like
it would take most people months of
planning to do what he did in real time
and I would see him do it or he would
say you stand here you stand here you
walk over here for this line then we
walk over here and then you two walk out
here and then that's it we start a 20
millimeter lens we track over here we
cut on this line then pick it up 30
millimeter lens go behind you walk over
here stop cut on this side then for the
last three lines we bring you out in
this camera goes out that door another
camera picks you up you go out the door
and it was just like you were just he
was just like what like it's like it was
it was miraculous like it was something
that knowing how hard it is to do that
that I'd be like oh like generally that
would at least be like several hours of
conversations that people are having
looking at blueprints of the set how to
block it how to make sure that people
are lit backlit giving the right
opportunities for all this stuff and he
would just do it and and then it was
amazing like yeah and so that's what
also I took away was just like oh he is
like an inhuman ability to process how
to make a scene work from a cinematic
perspective you know
um yeah it was it was weird to watch at
times the other thing is that every
person who he works with is the Michael
Jordan of their position yeah oh yeah
I've worked with a lot of those people
which also was nice because it was
demystifying like I I made a film with
the honors Kaminsky uh he shot funny
people and so I knew a lot of the camera
Department as well uh I know uh Rick
Carter I I had gotten to know actually
coincidentally over the last few years
because he was kind of helping us out on
another project so
um it was
yeah they're all so good and great and
friendly and funny and they it feels
like you're getting invited to play on
their team kind of because they all know
each other so well and
um yeah and and it is like a real
camaraderie and it does feel like at
times like like those scenes of the
movie where it's like a bunch of kids
making a movie like that's what his sets
kind of felt like at times what is he
like what is Spielberg like when he is
giving you notes on set and is it at any
point did you want to take out your
phone and film him giving you notes
because it's I mean it's Steven
Spielberg directing you he didn't what's
funny is
like I did not receive a lot of
Direction I cannot and he he does not
he's not one of those directors who's
like going out of his way to direct
things that he doesn't uh you know that
he's happy with you know and so yeah
there were entire days where we would
talk a lot but none of it was about the
what I was doing performance standpoint
and so it was nice honestly yeah like in
a weird way I honestly could not really
it was like logistical Direction like
could you say the line here instead of
here like could you stop there and turn
like you know things like that could you
hold the look because we pushed in a
second longer and then say the line like
it was things like that it was very like
it was it was a lot of and I respond
very well to that type of Direction
where it's like about how to make the
shot work it's not about like the
emotionality of the scene the subtext of
the scene it's literally like you need
to be standing in front of this light
when you say that last line just make
sure that by the time you get there
you're standing there you know and like
like that that's just as hard as
anything you know but it's it's good
direction you know um yeah uh I'm just
about out of time with you but I have to
bring up uh one of my favorite shows on
TV is the boys ah thanks and um I know
that you know Eric told me they're
halfway through filming season four
right now and diabolical I'm wondering
what's going on if that's gonna get
picked up so I guess it's two-parter
yeah is there gonna be more boys
diabolical and um what can you tease
about season four man I don't know if I
can necessarily teach anything about
season four other than like you know
just what I think I can't be more
shocked by what they're doing over there
they find a way to shock me even more
um and we have
we have the college gen V show which
I've been starting to see episodes of
and it's
um completely insane
um and yeah I mean yeah just like the
combination of superheroes in a college
setting in an incredibly subversive
R-rated world is yeah there are parts of
that show where me and Evan are watching
the cuts of the sequences that were just
like dear God would have what if what
are they doing over there
um and I hope diabolical comes back
we've actually they they bought some
scripts for the next season so we've
been writing them we're not 100 sure
they will produce them but if everything
goes as planned they will produce the
scripts that that we are writing right
now that's actually great though because
um I think Amazon has done uh really
well with that and also Invincible you
know yeah that I've been working on too
I've been working on the next few
seasons of that and
um it's amazing also great which yeah
we're also producers on that so it's
they've been very supportive of letting
us do this crazy stuff it's truly uh
yeah we're doing sausage party with them
as well it's like they really um yeah
they really let us spend their money in
irresponsible ways I gotta go but I'm
gonna say it's very responsible because
you've been entertaining me and a lot of
other people I want to say thank you and
congrats on fablemans thank you very
much